Hello Freak bitches.
I've been baking bread lately.
Holy Shit.
Sour dough bread.
Sourdough bread.
It's very good for you.
It is.
Has Gluten though.
Yeah.
Natural process.
But sour dough bread apparently has
way less gluten than regular bread.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Cause my wife can eat that mechanic.
The other brand really.
It's a cool thing.
It just takes the,
you just take flour and water.
You need a starter,
which is culture.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You just start with a flour and water
and the natural yeast that comes from
around us in the environment
goes in and starts eating that.
What?
And it becomes a living thing and people
have starters that have like a hundred
years old.
You take,
you take a couple ounces
off and you always maintain
a little and feed it like a
living thing.
It's like a bowl of flour and water.
But it's,
you'll see it start to bubble when you
feed it more flour and water east to
seating it.
Yeah.
It's the coolest.
That's crazy.
So it's in your refrigerator.
Like what's in my fridge?
Like a little little a mason jar.
Wow.
And then you scoop it out,
you just take a little chunk of
it in the feed it and it expands,
and then you take some of
that and make bread out of it.
That is fucking nuts.
It's pretty,
yeah.
So never would have been into this
if I didn't hear that concept.
And now I can't stop baking bread,
like Little Red Riding Hood.
Who gave you the idea to do this?
This writer friend of mine,
he's been doing it for
a long time and he said,
it's just,
you just have sourdough bread
and the kids love it and wow.
I just started doing it and uh,
I just got hooked on it.
What do you buy your starter?
You don't buy it.
You can just start it.
Make a starter,
make a starter.
Okay.
How do you do that?
You just take some flour and
water and put it out on the,
on the counter.
That's it.
Yeah.
I mean there's measurements and stuff,
but that's it.
And then the natural yeast,
there's east around us
just floating around.
That explains a lot of things.
Yeah.
And it goes into,
it goes into the,
uh,
into the concoction and as you'll see,
it starts to bubble and get lighter
and you feed it some more and it gets
bigger.
When you say feed it like for you,
cause it's sweet.
It's like a yeast,
a little like a little community,
right.
Feeding it equal parts.
A flour and water.
Wow.
And it eats it.
And now it's like this living thing in
the house who has a star that's a hundred
years old.
I went to buy a Dutch oven,
which is like a pot that you can bake.
You put the bread in and
this old guy was like,
what are you doing?
Even the guy who Williamson,
I was like,
six foot lanky.
What do you need it for?
I'm like,
I'm going to make some bread.
Oh,
I've been making bread for a long time.
Really?
I'm going to be making sourdough bread.
Oh,
I got my start.
Or where are you getting your starter?
I said,
well,
a friend of mine has the Bray a starter
and my daughter Labrea what's the of
starter?
That one.
Is that all the Bray
libray of bakery bread,
you get the yeast off
of the skin of grapes.
So there's a process where you take
grapes and you put it in like cheesecloth
and you just let the,
the yeast come off of all,
all grapes have yeast in the skin,
eating on the skin of the
grapes and that drips off.
And then you put it into the basic
starting with the flour and water.
So it has real sweeter,
brave say chain.
Is that what it would be like?
Yeah,
there's,
you'll see them there are actual bakery
and now they're like in Ralph's and
everything that's all over.
And they say,
and like the places San Francisco
that have big sourdough,
that it all,
it's maintains the same started
that they've always had.
So this guy said,
uh,
so I told him where I
was getting my stuff.
My daughter made one as a gift and
then this other guy gave me a piece,
he said his starter
came from Jackson Hole,
Wyoming and he got it
from a friend of his,
and it's over a hundred years old.
People have been passing
it on to cowboy starter,
cowboy starter.
That's what it was.
It was a lot of minors in San Francisco
and all that during the gold rush.
They were creating bred that way.
That's where it started.
No,
Huh.
Yeah.
I wonder how old the yeast organisms
get before they die and do they die?
They probably reproduce and yeah,
it's a good question.
I don't know because basically like I
have it on my counter nab and feeding it
for the last day.
So now,
so now it's kind of bubbly,
wow.
Glue and it's kind of bubbly.
So I'll scoop out four ounces of that,
make bread out of it,
and then take one ounce of that,
put it back in the jar,
feed it a little and put it in the fridge.
So what's the process?
So if you took four ounces
out and made bread with it,
what do you do with that?
The starter?
Uh,
you basically take a lot of flour.
You take like 28,
this is to make two of them two loaves.
You Take uh,
uh,
28 ounces of all purpose
flour or wheat flour,
whatever you want to use.
You put that in with a little salt.
Then you take your starter,
you take the four ounces
and an 18 ounces of water,
a bunch of water,
and you make it into a cloud,
a mixture,
and then you dump that into the flour
and salt that's in your mixer and it just
makes it into dough and then
it just rises naturally.
Bold it a couple of times,
put it into a ball,
into the Dutch oven after a couple
hours and then you've got bread.
It's that simple.
How long before you start growing your
own wheat and smashing up with a rock?
I'm,
I'm headed that way.
That is the guy who,
who I bought the Dutch oven from is like,
I really like seed breads
and then I looked it up.
That's like crazy.
12 different seeds from different
places and you mash them up.
I mean then then you're getting a job
at Williams Sonoma.
I went to the Museum of
natural history and they had a,
an Egyptian mummy display.
Really fucking cool.
Um,
but one of the interesting things was
by the time Egyptian people were older,
you know,
they didn't leave that live that long,
but if they did,
they didn't have any teeth left
because the way they made bread,
they ground it up.
They ground up their own flour
and it left sand in the bread.
Yeah.
Rose.
So their bread was all you
were eating sand wear away,
your teeth had,
it's great.
I thought you were going to say sugar,
no sand.
Oh,
wear your teeth down.
Line the down nerves.
And they had all these methods that they
were trying to concoct to save teeth,
like wooden caps that they would put
on chew on that instead of chewing with
whatever nerve endings
were left in your face,
just so you could eat more sand breads.
Sandy bread,
it's fucked up.
It is a kind of a trippy thing that you
just put some flour and water and this
yeast comes from the environment and now
you've got this amazing tasting bread
that the family can't stop eating.
The kids writing it.
It's just,
especially,
butter's been around for forever,
right out of the oven when it's hot,
we're eating bread like crazy.
Like when you're talking about like
eating sugar and all that flat,
we just can't stop.
Wow.
We're all going to be fun.
I'm going the other way.
I'm not eating any of it.
At least for 60 days,
I'm going to,
I don't feel,
I don't feel mentally that clear.
Have you?
Making some life choices.
Big Regret.
I told you I woke up at
seven this morning like,
oh,
I gotta do a show tonight and the players,
that's the brand.
It is the is man the bread.
It's making me lazy you down.
It's just so weird,
so weird that you could just like put it
out there and the natural yeast grows.
I had no idea.
I felt like I,
you know what,
I wish someone had asked me
where does east come from?
Cause I never considered it before.
I would have been like
a fucking what is it?
A plant.
What is our,
I don't know.
And then there's like,
you know,
cause you can buy a yeast that just make
regular bread and you throw it in there
and it eats.
Wow.
The Flower Toman maintains 122
year old sourdough starter.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Whoa.
There was a woman on line who's this?
Radical feminists who made sourdough
bread out of her pussy east.
Yeah.
Go find that one Jamie.
And couldn't keep their hands off it.
Oh,
it was fucking flying off the shelves.
Yeah.
I tweeted about it,
but it was quite a while ago.
Probably never find it,
but I was like good for her.
There is,
I can't tell you.
It's really a weird thing.
I mean,
who I haven't done it would
never be baking bread.
I don't know.
I'm like hooked on it.
Yeah.
There it is.
A woman who made sourdough bread using
yeast from her vagina just ate the bread
thrown.
Ah,
I wouldn't cheat.
You know,
I would eat
my own column.
Donut
gross.
Why is it so gross when I eat it?
But when my wife swells
that it's all gravy.
That's a good relationship.
Life is built.
Yeah.
It's a compromise.
So I'm baking bread and getting fat.
Bread's good.
What's that?
It's not good for you Tom.
Papa.
I know.
We started a resurgence.
Oh,
you brought bread.
You son of a bitch.
Oh,
it's wrapped in a cloth.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Like,
like,
like he's some old timey
baker character through.
It feels like the only thing
I'm bummed out about us.
I didn't have a basket to bring it in.
Did you make that?
This is a sour dough.
This is a sourdough bread from Tom
Papa that made it into New York Times.
Yeah.
When I did your show and uh,
can I smell it?
Talks about it.
Yeah.
This is a couple of days old cause I
thought it was coming a couple days ago.
Ooh.
Did you even make the
top a little flowery,
like,
like a real bakery?
Let me smell
it.
Smell so good.
It's good.
God that smells good.
Yeah,
that's ancient sourdough.
Tom,
Papa,
you fucking animal.
You brought a knife and everything.
I don't,
it looks like we're off the Diet today.
Today I was at the lowest weight.
I've been in like years,
so really one 90 this morning.
I really,
yeah,
it was crazy.
How tall are you?
Five.
Eight.
Wow.
I really,
uh,
I don't think that this bread,
this is sourdough bread.
You digest it as a lower
glycaemic supposedly.
Supposedly.
Allegedly.
I'm in though,
Dude.
Just slice it up.
Put It on this.
This is a couple of days off.
So granted this,
this table,
it actually be good.
Like it'll make it cooler.
So he just cut it like
it's a cutting board.
Don't be shy.
All right.
This is a,
I mean this is how bread
was made originally.
This is an ancient Egypt
up thousand years ago.
Ancient Egypt.
Do you know that in ancient Egypt,
when they made bread,
they ground their flour
on like mortar and pestle.
But they were really shitty and so
they'd get a lot of sand in the flower.
So the people in ancient
Egypt all had fucked up teeth,
like worn down to the nerves
cause they were chewing sand,
all that.
So the inside of their
body was like a fucking,
what are those things called?
And Birds.
What does that called?
Like a,
um,
like uh,
what is that thing?
That thing that they do?
The crop where your,
your,
your gizzard.
Yeah.
You have your
fucking rocks in there
and you chew up your food.
Oh God.
Which is apparently one of the reasons
why they made ledge shot illegal in
California.
Cause like if people do like shooting
clays or if they shoot things and those
little lead pellets
from shotguns,
birds will actually eat those.
Oh.
And it goes in there.
They're gizzard and they use it to,
uh,
to grind things up,
but then they get lead poisoning.
That's the thing with
the California condor.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons
why a California condors,
um,
one of the reasons why they made led
illegal for ammunition in California is
because of California condors.
Cause they wouldn't hear it dumped fucks.
So eating pellets,
not a rock.
You stupid fuck condor.
They look dumb.
They have Damas far.
They really do.
But we need them.
This should they toasted.
Toasted would really be the thing that
would get you way to tie right now.
Folks.
Here we go.
So happy to see you eat bread.
This has a good,
it's pretty good.
I was nice and airy.
I make the,
I we haven't bought bread
since I started this.
How long ago was that?
December.
Wow.
We have not bought bread.
Do you know what like bread in uh,
in your supermarket,
this is made with three ingredients.
Flour,
water and salt.
That's it.
That's,
you know,
from your sourdough starter bread,
like the healthy,
like whole wheat bread,
you just get it.
Ralph's or whatever.
32 ingredients.
32.
This is pure.
And is that just because it preserved
preserved preservatives and flavors and
yeah,
people get so mad when they eat.
On a microphone.
I know,
but it's so good.
Normally folks,
I would never do this to you and I'm
only doing this to you because Tom Papa
brought some breaded and I'm going
to break my diet for a few hours.
The sour dough flavor,
like that little after flavor
and the top of your mouth.
It's an that's a bacteria that's
lactobacillius or something like that.
No.
Yeah,
this is really good.
You're in a excellent bread guy.
It's pretty cool.
Standup comedy thing doesn't pan out.
Dude.
I'm going to just go into it after doing
your podcast and then talking about it
on my podcast,
it just kind of erupted.
People were just so interested in just
this pure making something small and
simple and,
and uh,
I think I told you when I
saw you at the comedy store,
there's like,
you know,
you have some,
you have some real man listeners like
dudes who look like they're going to call
you for like advice on a
truck and they're like,
I can't get my starter right.
It's about,
there's some like,
and people would start
sending me pictures of,
there's bread and pictures of their
sourdough and then this guy from the New
York Times,
Sam Sifton,
the editor,
it was doing an article on it.
So he contacted me and that
was part of this sour dough.
This whole thing about people keep
their sourdough starter like a pet.
So it was kind of like this
revival of this little method.
So ended up in this article
in the New York Times.
Yeah.
Read it.
I had a lot of people send me
articles about starters to yeah,
like people in England that have
150 year old and all this crazy
shit weird.
It's so good that I had never even
heard about it until you brought it up.
I have no idea.
I had no idea either until a
month before that I had the,
I was under the impression
and knows with zero research,
just my head,
this is how you make bread.
I thought you'd take flour
and water and eggs and yeast.
Yeah.
You add yeast for Easton
and that's all I thought.
I didn't,
I never knew that you had like
they could take flour and mix it with
water and then you get yeast out of the
air.
Yeah.
When you told me that and I was like,
yeah,
get the fuck out of here.
That's crazy.
Just floating around us all the time,
which is,
you know,
that's what the case with
nitrogen [inaudible].
Yeah.
Like the reason why there's
so many people on this planet,
and this is from a radio lab
podcast that highlighted,
I think it was called the bad show,
but the,
the radio lab podcast was highlighting
how sometimes really bad people do really
good things or really good.
It's sometimes it's difficult
to differentiate between
someone who's bad or good
because what they've done is so amazing.
Right.
Well,
this is a guy named Fritz harbor,
and Fritz Haber was a
scientist in Germany,
and what harbor did was he figured out
a way to extract nitrogen from the air
because apparently our
air is mostly nitrogen.